[Applaudissements]
quelque chose que la france et les
français ne peuvent pas tolérer
nous avons de forts soupçons qu'une
personne sur ce plateau ne portait pas
je dis bien ne portait pas de culotte
au cours de cette émission à l'autre
si je veux dire comme ça mais
apparemment il y avait un
révolutionnaire un sans culotte
autour de la table jamais je vous
propose de regarder les images et on
convoquera cette personne juste après et
les yeux dans les yeux
cette personne nous dira si oui ou de re
culotte
or notre culotte là est la question
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr bien sûr chez vous vous l'aurez
compris la personne dont on parle et
c'est gilles dernier caroline
c'est à la demande de caroline de ce
qu'elle voulait aussi répondre aux
téléspectateurs parce que sur twitter il
ya eu un déferlement sans culotte sans
pantalon c'est le roi dagobert
voila voila chouette la hulotte caroline
venez vous expliquer s'il vous plaît
merci partie car oui
[Applaudissements]
fo demandé d'enlever aux chaussures
parce que je ne peux pas vous regarder
dans les yeux
c'est bien comme ça on est bien
caroline avant de vous poser la question
fatidique
je vais lancer bien sûr le hashtag la
sphère de la culotte fellow the cloud
gate caroline les yeux dans les yeux et
ce qui y est vous aviez oui ou non une
culotte sur le plateau hier oui je
n'avais pas de culotte
j'avais bien sans culotte
j'ai bien dit ligne oui mais comme plein
de française je crois que c'est 70 % des
françaises d'accord donc tu mettes ne
vais pas tout va bien ni de sortie n'est
de jo wilfried tsonga sont nombreux
c'est le fait qu'en fait tu es n'était
malheureusement pas prévu je ne savais
pas je ne fais pas que j allais faire
importer d'accord voilà
mais j'ai été très bavard contre en
temps réel très sérieusement j'ai été un
peu traumatisés par le parfum purr voilà
c'est vrai elle a été traumatisée donc
voilà
caroline rassurez vous elle était bien
qu'ouverte voilà et c'était important
merci caroline merci c'était important
que le pq
[Applaudissements]